semaines et des mois vous le savez jean
pierre pernaut nous a quittés vous
acquittez car je crois que tout le monde
tout le monde tout le monde aime écouter
absolument jean pierre pernaut et pour
la première fois est bien à sa femme
nathalie qu'on embrasse très fort qui
venait souvent ici est une femme
charmante on a fait un documentaire avec
mets délicieux ses enfants aussi plutôt
mellouk j'embrasse très fort et bien
pour la première fois des sorties du
silence pour rendre hommage à son mari
regarde et d'être toujours été fort et
s'est toujours battu pour sa famille il
avait envie de rien lâcher et ma
nourriture plus pour que la famille soit
bien pour qu'elles manquent de rien
c'est pour ça qu'ils voulaient pas
tellement au départ prendre sa retraite
mais moi je dis mes cibles moi je veux
je veux je veux tu profites de nous
voilà on avait hâte de pouvoir être
ensemble quoi affaire un vieux couple
quoi comme tout le monde mais jean bien
n'est pas comme tout le monde quoi il ya
des trucs qui me faisait rire tu te
rends compte le jour où toi tu vas
mourir chéri j'ai dit mais tu te rends
compte ça va être chiant pour moi parce
que ça va être insupportable à gérer
comment je vais gérer parce que ça va
être horrible il dit mais non mais
t'inquiète pas comme je serai plus à tf1
tout le monde va oublier mais voilà
chéri ben tu vois si tu m'entends bien
non les gens l'aiment toujours les gens
sont toujours fidèles dont je voulais
remercier de son public voilà et un
skate très tôt j'en sais que isabelle où
l'on va on l'a dit on l'a su et venait
de déménager ils ont alors ni temps
plein dans les cartons exactement une
étude à acheter une autre maison venait
de déménager voilà donc ça veut dire que
cette femme qui se trouvait que ses deux
enfants et qui n'a rien vu venir puisque
vous l'avez très bien expliqué c'est pas
le cancer qui l'a tuée se retrouvent
tous ne jouent que c'est le stress de
lainage mans se retrouve dans un
déménagement dans le jir et où on a
enlevé tout est à faire oui les
souvenirs et tout avec ses deux gamins
pour une maison vide c'est ça l'histoire
absolument oui epide vous touchera le
temps puisqu'elle tend à georges
pompidou aller passer ses jours et ses
nuits à l'hôpital où est donc c'est oui
c'est donc elle est gérée absolument
tous en même temps moi je les trouvais
absolument est ce qu'on dit toujours
cette jeune femme si si bien fait vive
et sweet tooth là elle a vraiment mais
assurée elle assure toujours évidemment
et elle va à l'école qu'elle est calé le
voit il est resté trois semaines
l'hôpital où il était trop faible ce qui
est des gens qui allait le voir de temps
en temps à moi je pense que les visites
étaient totalement interdites
par rapport aux virus et puis par
rapport à son état de santé puis n'était
pas en état de le voir personne hommes -
donc elle elle était vraiment là le
gardien du temple quoi mais pour le
moment on était en train de parler de
jean pierre pernaut parce que forcément
les a quittés cette semaine j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'hommages
tout le monde tout le monde aime jean
pierre pernaut ça c'est sûr et on disait
effectivement que vous vous l'avez quand
je vais très bien puisque ses
chroniqueurs de l'ine souvient sa
diversité
j'ai été chroniqueur gill a été l'autre
pas honte et les a bataillé à moi va
commencer 80 ans 81 ans combien ça coûte
voilà il me l'a appris plein de trucs
qui nous a surtout appris à parler au
pot à un public populaire et à rendre
compréhensible des choses qu'il n'était
pas dans le solaire par exemple quand on
faisait l'argent par les fenêtres
qu'était la claque chronique importante
de combien ça coûte avec les ponts trop
bas à tous qui avait coûté beaucoup
d'argent contribuables ils nous disaient
d'eux n'est pas des millions ou des
milliards dit qu'on veut ça fait
d'hôpitaux con mais ça fait deux oui
c'est ça smictom match mais vachement à
ça comme une obsession lisait sait
combien de rames de tgv c'est combien de
gars c'est qu'on aille à l'hôpital parce
que dire aux gens 500 millions ça leur
propre accord c'est bon voilà mais c'est
un type après on a un peu de tout dit
depuis trois jours c'est vrai mais on a
un extrait où le ça nous permet de le
voir et de vous voir ça c'est toujours
bon regarder
en direct
et bien sûr pendant toute cette soirée
comme d'habitude on va parler d'argent
parfois ça énerve parfois s'avérer et ce
soir vous le savez nous allons surtout
parlé de la nourriture c'est parce que
quand on va acheter à poulets dans un
magasin jouet à les prix
ça va de 20 francs à 100 francs enfin
bon les gars alors à quoi reconnaît-on
un bon poulet comme ça j'ai enlevé les
étiquettes andriel t elle je suis bien
plus blanc j'étais plus jeune je suis là
bah ouais mais vous avez annoncé le plus
cher alors on s'assoit dit j'y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vais aussi coucou c'est nous à l'époque
j'étais gamin c'est christophe
dechavanne qui produisent elles y
produisait et gsm ses gimmicks c'était
un grand c'est un grand journaliste a
bien sûr c'est vrai qu on le réduit
souvent au côté terroir le dernier
luthier août comme ça mais il a été
comme sur tous les théâtres d'opération
et je me suis surtout à tchernobyl soit
répété que c'était des zones il a été
remis à entrer dans la zone interdite de
tchernobyl 3 price était un scoop
incroyable 5en à l'image je crois
tout les fortes de cette centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl se sont ouvertes
pour notre équipe dirigée par françoise
marie morel toutes les portes et compris
celle de ce fameux réacteur numéro 4 qui
a explosé il ya quatre ans ici c'est la
détresse et l'impuissance qu'après une
zone contaminée qui est gigantesque des
centaines de villages évacués jusqu'à
300 km d'ici des populations malades 3
millions de personnes surveillées même
chose
vous avez l'honnêteté de reconnaître
qu'il ne voulait pas aller sur des zones
de conflit militaire qui pouvait mettre
en danger la vie de son équipe et la
diplomatie française et se trouvait que
c'était important c'est vrai qu'il
n'était pas inconscient du tout il ya
des fois où il disait de lui on line
devant vous pardon il va rencontrer
comment pour ce match aller rencontrer
parce que quand il a pris en charge le
13 heures on a dit tout l'intérêt james
iha parisienne a dit il va se planter il
ne marchera jamais mourousi t'adorer des
médias et et lui il est il est nul c'est
un regard un provincial et petit à petit
et c'est nous qui lui avons fait sa
première une de toute sa carrière ats
des et donc j'avais titre évidemment
vernon sinon rien pour reprendre une pub
célèbre à l'époque oui mais à l'époque
personne ne disait donc ils aideront
très heureux
mais je sais que chaque fois qu'ils me
voyaient dit je suis ton père nos sinon
rien déjà moi voilà et c'est est
l'antithèse de mourousi parce que c'est
un fait ninard mecque de la night
homosexuels bien parce que paris était
quand même risqué puis l'a fait une
longévité quand même 30 dans mois il a
commencé en 88 moi je suis né en 88 il
arrêté en 2020 en fait c'est tout
maintenant connus morizet vous non mais
je sais lire des articles
encore absolument et je t'ai qui était
alors on va parler aussi forcément
presse people aussi bah oui parce que
c'était c'est l'un des derniers
présentateur de jt qui est devenu un
people donc on est obligé de le dire sa
carrière et 1,10 au sein du secteur de
la presse people sa femme vous en veut
beaucoup ça qu'ils ont fait fuir à
saintes six couvertures ne serait-ce qu
il ya une année oui mais alors
particulièrement d'une presse people qui
est france dimanche ici paris c'est pas
la même parce que public closer voici et
c'est normal parce que c'est un
électorat plus rurales on va dire -
parisien que public closer et voici et
surtout ce qui est intéressant le
paradoxe chez le personnage jean pierre
pernaut c'est qu'ils parlaient beaucoup
de sa vie privée dans paris match
présenté ses enfants il il nous
racontait qu'il avait guéri de son
cancer de la prostate il l'a raconté en
septembre dernier il était tombé malade
et en même temps il ne supportait pas
d'être là proie des paparazzis de la
presse people qui le harcelaient il ya
un très drôle c'est que sa femme raconte
dans un documentaire parce qu'on avait
tourné nous un documentaire sur son fils
tom évidemment très gentiment
jean-pierre à jean pierre avait 10
juillet ce que voulait dans le
documentaire il si c'est pour monfils
oui il était tout le temps et il est
aussi nathalie et nathalie raconte une
anecdote façon fils aussi la raconte la
presse people je sais pas si c'est vous
avait titré nathalie son nouveau mec
qu'elle se baladait avec son fils tom
kessel en mai khai a été magnifique et
c'était tellement dur c'est tellement
choquant c'est là c'était pas nous mais
c'est bien on a on a souvent pris par la
poire on va dire les choses franchement
parce qu'en fait il ya un précédent qui
est la ferme célébrités où il ya eu la
rue bien sûr
et à partir de là il ya eu une rupture
entre cette presse-là et nathalie
marquay jamais réparé et forcément ce gt
vous
savez on dit que jean pierre était un
anti star system qui n'était pas une
star qui ne se prenait pas pour une star
tout ça est vrai je pense que le jour où
il s'est aussi marié que nathalie
marquay ça a changé sa vie en réalité
personne connaît la première femme de
jean pierre pernaut non dominique je
peux même pas en photo c'est vrai et que
il a épousé quand même une miss la plus
belle femme de france est un personnage
haut en couleur et c'est être contre ça
a changé sa vie et ça ils s'y
attendaient pas ils avaient tellement la
france il a épousé une miss miss france
c'est pourquoi il faisait des gars aussi
parfois voir enfin ce sera peut être
celle là c'était le 16 mai en 2011 il
invitait dauphin de jean pierre thorn
pernaut pardon invite carla bruni
sarkozy qui est enceinte elle ne l'a pas
dit personne n'a dit larry le sait et
puis va faire une gaffe rihaoui et puis
je sais que vous détestez qu'on parle de
votre vie privée mais j'ai envie
simplement de vous féliciter
je me félicite
merci merci merci ca une boulette
jean pierre pernaut avec la presse
people voilà il se livre à un exercice
de presse people en tirer et à people
exceptionnel un méchant c'est paradoxal
ans durant
la première année
et laura dernier mot parce qu'il était
je crois qu'il avait dit il avait aussi
eu son petit caractère il a fait il
était connu pour ses coups de gueule moi
je le voyais tous les ans à miss france
qu'il est très attaché évidemment à
l'émission je fais partie du comité miss
ile de france puis des fêtes
familiales ce mec est parti il fait ses
news divers britney spears et rihanna
ile de france mas un truc chez nous pour
que tout ça n'est pas son métier par
ailleurs
gagne donc on est très bien pions et
donc il y avait des rires donc chaque
année en fait on se retrouvait les pour
l'émission il faisait un petit live
juste avant pour présenter un peu les
coulisses et il était effectivement très
connu pour ses coups de gueule en a
quelques-uns rire les pharmacies qui
reste ouverte malgré le stade iii bat
toujours pas de masque non plus peu de
gel met beaucoup de monde la seule vraie
chose qui circule c'est le virus et
c'est dramatique c'est un peu comme la
radioactivité est une menace qui est
partout et on la voit pas c'est pour ça
que les inconscients n'en tiennent pas
compte ils ont tort vous vous trouvez
qu'il ya suffisamment les gens
respectent suffisamment les distances de
sécurité
ou encore de gens sourire et pourtant
ce matin les passants étaient nombreux à
s'interroger sur l'utilité du port du
masque dans la rue finalement ni les
vélos ni les coureurs n'auront besoin de
le porter et on a compris que quand on
marche on doit avoir un masque et si on
voit un policier il suffit de protein et
on a droit de l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
à la famille